I think that girls into you the  SuperDuper pretty girl with the brown  hair  wait so he really likes you no I  I think she's into you  no I don't think she's even looking at  me man she's looking right through me  that hunk of a guy oh is it he really  likes you  oh no God each other's type a guy like  me no way man  she's too classy the ones perfection hey  no yeah don't do it don't go you're  probably right it's like always better  to play it say you know what I'm gonna  go over there yeah I'm gonna go over  there  hi my friend thinks that wow this is  weird how do we stop this umbrella  cucumber a dog with rates for hands I  just want to ask your number sure really  cool well at least this won't be the  same 5 3 1 5 6 2 4 2 2 4  9 sorry for 2 to 9 but everything else  was the same finally work  my mom's name is Cheryl what you're  gonna Cheryl hey